there are researchers who are working on
this is how life in general arises in
General trying to abstract from Earth's
chemistry and look at
what life fundamentally is what is the
distinction between
when matter is
ruled by the laws of physics and when
something else kicks in one of the big
challenges to that is that we don't have
a theoretical understanding of what life
is I talk in the book and people often
ask me about like we don't have a
definition for life and it's true we
don't but that's not because we haven't
found it yet it's because life isn't the
sort of thing for which definitions are
useful
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic welcome
everybody to what promises to be a very
Lively and lifelike discussion of the
possibility in the actuality of life
with none other than friend of the
friend of the show
Jamie green how are you Jamie hi I'm
good thanks for having me
joining us from the spiciest state of
all the Nutmeg State yeah not far from
where I had my own origin of life event
long long ago but you are a good friend
and and a colleague or at least a
partial partial connection to my friend
Shelly Wright an esteemed Professor here
one of my highest greatest
accomplishments is that I was on the
search committee leading it to hire
Shelley and it's just such a delight to
have her and I wouldn't know about you
without her because she tweeted out uh
this wonderful book by her friend Jamie
green and uh and it was on Twitter and
then I try to find you on Twitter just
to you know tweet at you to remind you
about this and I can't find you anymore
what happened did their Twitter bird die
or are you still on Twitter I am okay
that's a lot my name is very easy to
misspell so
well isn't the rule that Jamie as a man
is with an ie and with a for a female
it's a i artificial no no it's not
because
a lot of female Jamie's also spell it
j-a-m-i-e like in that form it's sort of
short for James but it's also like the
demit I don't know
it's you know my parents wanted it to be
spelled interestingly and they succeeded
yeah it's got Ai and it's got me in it
and it's got a j so that's a French two
so it's got everything it's good I am me
and I am also French for artificial
intelligence hey it's great to meet you
digitally we've been talking for weeks
and weeks now about this possibility of
getting you on the show and you said yes
so Jimmy we pulled out all the stops we
normally have a nice pink Hue in the
background here at the into the
impossible Studios but now you'll notice
there's a green issue that's just for
you ah subtle subtle hint
uh and speaking of visual Delights the
cover of this wonderful book is is
beautiful it's artistic and it's
mesmerizing and as we discussed the
first thing I always talk about when I
have an author grace me with her
presence on my podcast is to judge her
book by its cover
so I'm asking you to now take out the
copy that you have I have it in audio
and printed form and describe the title
the origin story of the title the cover
art and the subtitle of this wonderful
new book so the possibility of life I
had known that
this would be the title I had the idea
to write a book like this or a book
about this topic for over a decade and
that was always the title that I had in
mind
um that was the title of the essay
series that I wrote in like
2017 or so that led to this book because
it just
it captures everything about it for me
you know it's that it is a phrase that's
familiar oh the possibility of life on
other worlds the possibility of Life
etc etc but I like not putting the of on
other worlds on it you know and it's
just all the possibilities and that's
also what it means to me that it's not
just oh what's the possibility of Life
on Mars it's
what are all of the possibilities of
life itself so that that had always been
been with me the subtitle was as often
happens in publishing something that was
ironed out through a lot of
brainstorming between me my agent my
editor
um
they really didn't want aliens or
extraterrestrials to be like named in
the subtitle I think when I was first
writing the book and when I wrote the
book proposal
the subtitle was something like how we
imagine aliens and my publisher wanted
it to be a lot broader
um
and so I I sent them a a bunch of
possibilities and they went for this one
science imagination and our quest for
kinship in the cosmos
um in the UK it has a slightly different
subtitle uh
I was just put a u in there somewhere
they put an extra extraneous year
although they say Cosmos um fantastic
like uh
Cosmos I don't know they they pronounce
Cosmos in a way that I wouldn't expect
but it's just um searching for kinship
in the cosmos is the UK subtitle and um
okay yeah the UK so the book came out in
the UK in the Commonwealth the same week
it did in the US but it has the
different subtitle and a totally
different cover which even like further
abstracts the alien-ness like all of
this looks like it reminds reminds me of
the Burgess Shale like it looks like
ancient you know um flora and fauna but
they're all Fantastical you know
combinations of of real things
um I feel like this the UK cover really
Echoes the cover for um
Merlin sheldrake's entangled life which
is a book that I adore
that my UK publisher was using as a comp
title and I was like I hadn't read it at
that point I was like okay this is a
book about fungi like I get that it was
a big seller and you want to compare my
book and then I read it and I was like
oh no this is actually even though it's
about fungi a very similar approach of
just looking at the scientific question
through the science and also through
what it means to us as people
um so I was like yeah I am happy for the
cover in the UK to sort of
um echo or evoke associations with that
book but in the US
um
it's this lovely sort of Illustrated
cover
um and I very early on in the process
because I am a bossy overachiever
um created a mood board for covers for
my publisher before they had you know
even asked because I wanted to make sure
that it didn't look just like an
astronomy book that when you looked at
the shelf and I knew it would be on the
science shelf but I wanted it to be
clear that it is about science but is
also
about culture about meaning
um I wanted it to feel a little more
literary sort of that like if someone
loves reading essays that they'll know
that this is a book for them so I made
this mood board with a lot of Art and
some covers that I liked I knew that I
didn't want it to be like black and navy
blue
you know which is what so many most
books right
um like this book behind me that she can
can't I mean that's mine it's my first
book it's right because it's really it's
conveying specifically what it is and
this I have a lot of Science and a lot
about space but it's not an astronomy
book
um no and so actually this image on the
cover is by an artist who I follow on
Instagram and I put some of her work in
the mood board and my publisher decided
they really liked her work and um
said go to her site and pick three to
five images that I feel like would be a
good background and this was one of them
uh or is this the second one
there was a lot of back and forth
because the first cover that they put
together with her work was beautiful and
looked like an astronomy book
and I was like this is a beautiful cover
but it's not the right cover for my book
um so it took a lot of work to to get
the right feeling to find the right
fonts that were like serious enough but
not too serious I really cared about the
mood but I I love this cover so much you
know the fact that it's
a view of a planet and stars but it has
a very Illustrated feeling
um and has a Whimsical but it's also
exactly evocative exactly and you know
has has pinks and oranges and in
addition to the the requisite dark
purple and the star field so I yeah I uh
I love it very much well I appreciate
you setting the record for describing
and judging the book by its cover
because normally when I have somebody on
they say oh my publisher chose it and
they told me what title it was but yeah
it sounds like you like me are a little
bit of a control freak when it comes to
books especially your first book like
your first kid you tend to over control
them but uh you loosen up if you if you
do have more children iPhone
um so behind you don't uh you don't have
to pull it out is a book by past guest
uh or I should say husband and father of
past guest uh Sasha Sagan and andrewian
and that's Cosmos and Cosmos makes a
knot in insignificant role in this book
and I want to read a quote that I'd
never heard before I read your lovely
book and it was
um it is the following here it says Carl
said in
1973 this is incredible he was talking
about an encyclopedia for constructing
or discovering life he quoted Thomas
Carlisle and he says a somewhat crusty
old fellow upon thinking about the Stars
said a sad spectacle if they be
inhabited what scope for misery and
Folly if they are not inhabited what a
waste of space and of course that plays
a big role in the movie contact
featuring probably
um uh the the caricature of past guest
and friend of the show Jill Tarter as
you talk about in the book but Sagan
says I suspect we'll be talking about
this is it possible that in a universe
teeming with stars and planets there is
not a multitude of other inhabited
worlds and if there is a multitude of
inhabited worlds Carl said then what is
the nature of their inhabitants and what
are the possible aspects of our contact
with them I don't know if you know this
about me but I'm a skeptic I don't
believe uh I believe with very high
levels of confidence that not only is
there no technological life elsewhere in
the universe but there may not be any
other life in the universe besides that
which came from Earth via a process you
discussed called panspermia we'll get
into that uh where do you fall are you
did you come away from this book did you
enter this book with a preconceived
notion that you're going to fulfill the
Ellie Arrow Way like dreams uh your
favorite your favorite name and all of
uh literary history did you come away
with a hope you know you'd prove it or
did you come away somehow discouraged uh
what how did you start off to chart your
own non-biological but your Evolution
ideological Evolution throughout the
writing of this book I think
um
you know the so much of the premise of
the book and the the whole introduction
is about like most books on this topic
are about
skepticism versus optimism about likely
unlikely common rare unique you know
what are the odds
um
and I really set for myself the goal of
not talking about odds in the book that
part of what the title means to me is
that
I want to look at what are the
possibilities if there is life what
might it be like if there is life how
could we understand it how could it help
us understand life on Earth what would
we learn from it
um so I do think that
in making that decision I sort of it's
sort of like inhabiting a role that
you're acting I really came to take up
that mindset where it's it's like a real
agnosticism where it's like I don't know
um and
I do think that when people
including Carl Sagan himself say how
could there be
so many stars so many planets and no
other life my answer is like well there
absolutely could be you know this
happened with with the jwst Deep Field
image people would post that and say
look at all this how could we be alone
and I'm like well very easily let me
tell you how
um and and especially when people mean
how could we be the only
conscious animals how could we be the
only technological civilization
um quite possibly that's one where
the more I learned especially in terms
of learning about the origin of life and
the origin of complex life uh it does
seem like like my feeling is
we don't really know because we only
have one example and so we have no idea
if you know this is the common way for
planets to go or what
um but the the one thing that I think we
can extrapolate from is that life seems
to have emerged on Earth just about as
soon as conditions allowed
um
and that to me makes it feel like you
only have to roll the dice a few times
before you get life but then going from
roughly bacterial life
to
cells with complex inner structures
which were able to evolve
multicellularity structural complexity
you know plants animals people all of
that it was about 2 billion years
and that's a lot of rolling the dice and
I feel like the origin of eukaryotic
cells feels lucky there are very smart
people who argue the odd in the other
direction
um you know I am not a
evolutionary biologist I'm I don't have
a PhD in anything but you know it just
it's so hard to say because so much of
the optimism is inspired by a desire
yeah it wants a faith-based statement
yeah it's
give it as a faith-based statement
because I don't think it's based on no
information but it is inspired by
what we want to be true which I guess is
a way that you could look at Faith yeah
this belief versus evidence like I would
say I don't believe in gravity I have
evidence for Gravity right um and and
getting back to the point of the waste
of space that you talk about in the book
I I point out you know I've been to
Antarctica twice and Antarctica is one
seventh of the continents of the whole
planet Earth uh there is life there uh
there's about you know a couple billion
seagull-like creatures that are like on
seagulls on steroids called skus there's
a couple of billion Penguins but those
are only at the coast at the South Pole
there's nothing there's just people and
those are brought by large military
cargo planes so if you just said I'm
going to take a flat prior distribution
I'm going to say that equal probability
of being on equal land mass where
there's a continent in Antarctica uh
you'd be horribly wrong the biomass is
is insignificant compared to the
Continental Mass it's bigger than the
United States almost so you know for
those reasons I don't think that of prop
you know possibility you know to use a
the loaded word in your title which I
which I love
but that doesn't connote probability uh
and they're very different things right
yeah and and I think you know once you
get into
if the universe is infinite like yes
that when you when it's infinite then
you have a infinite me right so you then
you definitely have other but talking
about just sort of practically
um our galaxy yeah right because also if
we're hoping for a detection or
communication it's almost entirely
constrained to the Galaxy
um there has been work
um Jason Wright did some searching for
signs of possible like
basically like Mega civilizations in
other galaxies so there would be ways to
detect that but for the most part we're
talking about just within our galaxy
um
I also think that there's something
about when we look at all that space and
we say well surely there must be
life if there's that much space
otherwise what a waste of space that
rests on this assumption that life is
the purpose of the universe which is a
very logical statement exactly exactly
and um
you know I expect I wrote a piece when
those first jwsd images came out about
that impulse to see all that vastness
and say surely there must be something
else
um and I spoke to
an anthropologist Lisa massaria Yale who
studies
um you know how we engage with Space and
Science and Technology and she said
something fantastic which was
look at these galaxies they have their
own relationships like gravitational
relationships between each other they
don't need us to be meaningful to have
stuff going on you know we are not
necessarily the point there's other
stuff happening and I found that just
really
a really like moving way of looking at
it because we look for meaning in the
universe
um and one of the ways we do that is by
looking for life elsewhere in the cosmos
but I think also noticing and observing
and recognizing the absence of life or
the things that are
other than life
is also really important
why do you say that I'm I'm not I'm not
disagreeing but I think there's there's
this notion I've talked to a lot of
atheists uh on this podcast and listen
to many you know people like Sam Harris
or uh even this this person uh wrote
this book called uh four thousand weeks
um uh blankie on his name he's a
philosopher maybe Oliver Berkman that's
his name and he talks about like what's
called Cosmic insignificance therapy
that the fact that we're so small
compared to you know let alone the
galaxy of the universe but we're small
compared to uh to the planet Jupiter but
uh what does that matter I mean a tiny
little virus 1000th the diameter of the
human hair shut down the entire planet
for the better part of three years so
size is irrelevant uh if you're talking
about like lifetime you know we live 75
years okay so the Galapagos tortoise
that lives 160 years is that more
significant than us I find with atheists
they're kind of they're kind of consumed
they say oh I see this Hubble Deep Field
or Webb Deep Field as you're discussing
and I'm just so filled with awe and and
it just gives me meaning and I'm where
do you get your meaning from as an
atheist necessary and I don't know your
your and that's not the point of this
question but how do you react to those
statements that that that somehow gives
you know gives obviates the teleological
purpose that you just mentioned by
saying oh well it's so vast and we're so
insignificant I don't find that very
convincing it's for me it's not about
insignificance and I find
my meaning on Earth engaging with you
know and and that was also part of the
process that I went through writing this
book was really coming to appreciate
life on Earth so much more which is
another part of my like I don't care
um you know it's wonderful to think
about and it's fascinating to think
about but I don't need the answers from
off-world
um but I
I find contemplating that vastness
I find it beautiful rather than
meaningful where it doesn't change
how I live my life
um it's sort of like it's the sublime a
little bit which I know is related to a
sense of insignificance
um
I think it's it's
an appreciation not of just aesthetic
Beauty but of
the diversity of existence
that life on Earth there's so much going
on there's so much life we have so much
occupying ourselves every day our daily
concerns political concerns
science relationships like more than any
one person can handle
and then there's so much more beyond
that
that it's so I think it's a diversity
thing where Lisa Missouri this
Anthropologist was specifically talking
about one of the early jwst images which
is of Stefan's quintet which is five
galaxies four of which are
gravitationally interacting the fifth of
which is just like in our view but is
not actually part of what's going on and
she talked about how we have an image
that shows us that these Galaxies have
some sort of relationship physically
they are in motion they are affecting
each other changing each other and
recognizing that
alienness of physics of astronomy
it's it's sort of like it takes me out
of myself for a second to realize that
there is something so big and so
different happening there it's sort of
the same thing like um you know
thinking about a different you know um a
bat for example or an octopus or some
Earth creature that because of their
environment and their different senses
has an incomprehensibly different
experience of the world
trying to imagine that is also a very
meaningful act for me and it's it's a
similar thing of like trying to connect
with things that actually can't be
connected with
that's right yeah I I agree for sure and
I think you know there's this notion
that uh the more we know we're sort of
endowed with with these abilities to
basically make ourselves inured to the
awe and majesty and you know I would say
scientists are kind of like on a daily
basis we see the equivalent of a Grand
Canyon or you know like you said the
Stefan's quintet and you're looking at
things that are billions or you know
hundreds of millions of light years away
we're talking about speculation in my
field and the cosmic microwave
background and the inflationary Epoch
when the universe might have come into
existence a trillionth of a trillionth
of a trillionth of a second after the
big bang and oh yeah we just that's
literally what I get paid to do so a lot
of times an ordinary normal person who's
not a scientist you know they see the
Grand Canyon this is awesome literally
it fills you with awe scientists
geologist season so oh that's uplift
that's a schist formation and and so
forth um but getting back to uh to the
book it has uh it has a thematic kind of
development where you start from you
know more primitive ideas and you move
into more very Advanced ideas leading up
to technology and so forth I wonder what
would it take you you detailed and I
love this because I I often bring this
up with my friends I say what would
happen the day after a life alien life
is discovered let's I'll suspend my
disbelief I'll say and I'll ask Sean
Carroll or something I'll say what would
happen and and they'll answer all would
be life transforming but I say no
nothing would happen the next day two
days later nothing would happen I'd say
the next day something yeah it would be
like but and there's proof of it because
you detail
seven different events claim discoveries
of extraterrestrial life or intelligence
in the last 50 years of the Drake
equation alone one of those is in the
movie contact it's actually not CGI
right Bill Clinton is standing on the
White House this discovery if it goes
down it will be the greatest discovery
this Rock speaks to us and that was a
real meteorite which by the way if you
have a edu email address you can get a
real meteorite from uh Brian keating.com
then go for it I will send you one uh so
it's all my students that I want to uh
encourage to to take pay advantage to
these awesome authors I get to how about
so
until maybe 20 20 you know 17 or
something that was still sort of hotly
contested is it this or in scientific
circles in other words for uh two
decades people lived with the notion
that that the public had in their mind
that alien life had been discovered and
yet it hadn't and nothing changed so do
you how do you feel about these from the
wow signal to
um uh to things like uh the the
phosphine life that pass guest Sarah
Seeger discussed on my podcast not long
ago uh which goes into the I would say
it appears on page A1 you know the New
York Times above the fold uh and then uh
when the retraction comes if it ever
comes it's on page c17 of the Saturday
paper that nobody reads so what do we do
about this the hype cycle of alien life
it's it's a real challenge because like
it's how science works there is like the
the phosphine paper that all you know
unless someone is being extremely
irresponsible they're saying we found an
interesting signal or artifact and we
think that we our team has done the best
that we can to eliminate other to you
know um cross off the list all the other
known sources for phosphine or ways that
a rock might look like this or uh
sources for this signal but um you know
further work is required there has not
you know the phosphine paper didn't say
we found life on Venus but
it's exciting and there isn't that much
room for nuance and headlines so I don't
really know I do you know
it is
sort of a problem not even a problem
it's just like it's how journalism Works
um it's ha it's what people want to talk
about
so I don't know I don't have a solution
for that
[Music]
um
and yeah I mean I remember there was a
leak of like just a couple months after
the phosphine story broke I think it was
the guardian leaked that um the
Breakthrough team at Berkeley had found
a signal that was clearly technological
and they hadn't yet figured out
what was up with it and that made big
news and everyone on that team I assume
was pretty frustrated because they're
like we weren't ready to talk about this
um and that made lots of headlines and
then I only found out that they had
figured out the Earthly origin of that
technological signal because someone
tweeted from the conference presentation
that the researcher gave saying oh yeah
we figured out it was you know whatever
it was on earth like that made no
headlines whatsoever and um
that's very tricky but as for what would
happen I think it also really depends on
what the find is is it a micro Bond Mars
it does is it a fossilized microbe on
mars or you know something kicking
around in the Clouds of Venus versus a
signal of clear technological origin or
other proof of a technological
civilization absolutely yeah hugely
different meaning
um and
I I think no matter what though there
are going to be people who don't care
for whom it doesn't affect their lives
they're going to be people who care and
are frustrated that there isn't more
information
or anything to do about it I think it's
extremely unlikely that even if we do
find technological evidence that we're
going to be able to enter into any sort
of conversation you know oh who are you
what do you do what are you like do you
have any ideas for climate change you
know the sort of stuff that Carl Sagan
dreamed of it would just have to be so
perfectly lined up perfectly timed so
close in space so similar in
cognition and language
um
that I think if we find a signal and
can't have a conversation
I think a lot of people are going to be
let down because that's what
both science and science fiction have
sort of primed them to hope for
yeah and actually I think the timing of
the 1996 you know Bill Clinton Ellie
arroway you know uh uh cement mashup
that that was also time when uh Dan
golden at Nasa was trying to Gin up more
funding and attention for astrobiology
and had been cut uh and so forth so that
was kind of you know propitious for them
perhaps but I think long term these
things do damage ultimately to the
researchers who promote it and you know
I've talked to Sarah Seeger she's a good
very good friend I've had her over
um and uh and she's you know and and I
think she's she's very cautious and and
capable but it's almost like an
irresistible Force especially for young
people when they find out you know
there's just an implication of what
they're doing and it kind of transcends
I always say you know there's an old
joke about professors that we have such
heated battles because the stakes are so
low uh there's some truth to that and if
you've ever attended a faculty meeting
but uh but but the bottom line is a lot
of what we do is significant but it's
not um it may not be meaning full in
that it gives an imbued sense of meaning
or purpose to scientists many of whom
who you know will say that they're you
know agnostic or or so forth and I'm not
I never claim you have to be religious
or practice anything to to have this
sense of wonder or awe
um I I will ask you at the end some
existential questions of the meaning of
life and andrewian who's an atheist as
well you know she she answered the you
know question of you know what do you
think is the most important piece of
advice to your former self and she said
you know to walk walk humbly act justly
uh and that was it and that's a quote
from the biblical book of Mika and I
said Ann you left off the last phrase
which is walk you know walk humbly with
your God and she was like yep that's
right I'm gonna leave it on but
obviously she has tons and tons of
meaning and she figures prominently in
here I see this book as sort of half um
you know like cultural anthropology and
as you say by learning about aliens
we're learning about ourselves do you
think that is um that is enough sort of
in a sense like is it enough to catapult
it from being culturally important but
not necessarily as maybe scientifically
well respected as you know Carl Sagan
never got inducted into the National
Academy of Sciences which he's
definitely deserved he was a phenomenal
scientist and you outlined many of the
scientific advancements and achievements
um do you think that there is still this
you know prosthetic forehead problem of
aliens that that Adam Frank has spoken
about he's also in the book do you think
that it can be made completely
legitimate like say high energy particle
physics if you are dealing with you know
tentacles and and crashes in Roswell and
stuff like that
I mean I think it can but I think that
the legitimate science wouldn't deal
with the tentacles and crashes in
Roswell but there is a lot of cultural
baggage I've also heard it called the
giggle Factor you know yes looking for
Little Green Men
um or women yes little green people
little green creatures
um it's so tricky I mean there are
quotes I have in the book that use men
to stand in for humans like well that's
just that's what they were saying
historically and the phrases we know it
is little green men and
but the image of Little Green Man is
very gender neutral which is the thing
that I'm sure someone other than me has
written about but I'm just like I'm not
interested in the the UFO stuff there
are other books on that
um
I do think that it has a little bit of
the giggle factor I think there's also
the question of what the scientific
rigor is this was a question I had going
into it in terms of seti which is like
What's the hypothesis is it just a
search because you know one of the many
various freelance jobs that I have is
um I work with graduate students
applying for National Science Foundation
graduate fellowships and I work with
them on their research proposals and
I've through that come to learn that for
that
for that Grant the NSF does not like to
fund open-ended questions I'm going to
go count how many fish are in this Lake
I'm going to characterize this whatever
they really want to see a hypothesis and
that's just something that's gotten in
my head as um
a way of showing I mean this doesn't
apply to the seti researchers but like a
way of
um critically engaging with the research
I think it's also an act of creativity
and Imagination to say here's my
hypothesis here's how I'm designing the
experiment but I made the mistake of
saying to a seti researcher like a
senior researcher not a graduate student
or anything like well but this work
isn't like hypothesis driven you're just
seeing if there's something out there
and he was like no no no no no this is
rigorous hypothesis driven we
hypothesize that within this space on
the sky within this frequency space that
we will see this sort of signal and we
go and test that hypothesis and so it's
sort of like you know you have the
entire
360 degree physical space of the sky or
the Galaxy around us and you have all of
the various frequencies that you could
be listening at and the various times
but it's just like
what is the difference between that and
a sort of open-ended
search
I don't totally know
um and I think that might be part of the
challenge
um in terms of
like is the hypothesis just someone is
out there
but it is a very important scientific
question and it's one worth asking
because I don't think that we should
assume that no one is out there we
should look you know like we have the
ability to look we have barely scratched
the surface and um if there is someone
out there transmitting at us like let's
I think it would be very foolish to not
check
right yeah the question is the Hawking
question that you bring up which is you
know whether we should advertise the
dinner menu for the residents of 51
Pegasus b
um I have a lot of questions for my
audience I have any solicit questions
you can answer them uh rather you can
ask me them on YouTube in the comments
section at Dr Brian Keating on YouTube
um or on Twitter or Instagram where I
sometimes post stuff and we'll link to
Jamie's lovely feeds there now that I
know that they're not dead they are in
fact not possibly alive they are
definitely alive uh so uh one question
comes from someone named little man and
he asks on Twitter is it reasonable to
consider abiogenesis as a science I know
it's an aggressive question and
assumptions are being challenged but the
assumptions that life start that people
start with who study this which don't
seem to be falsifiable nor is there any
experimentation showing life to a
non-life to life transition what am I
missing so what do you say to little man
uh over here uh on on Twitter yeah um is
it legitimate I I think it is I mean I
think the study of the origin of life is
a fascinating field to me and I touch on
it in the book and um I'm like very
interested in continuing to learn and
write about it
um there is an unanswerable question
which researchers in the field agree is
not what they are pursuing and not
something that will ever be answered
which is the historical question of how
life began on Earth
we don't have a time machine We're Not
Gonna Know It
um I mean in terms of all the Sci-Fi
that I speak for yourself speak for
yourself all right if you're working on
it that's cool but like there's even
there's an episode of Star Trek the Next
Generation where Q brings Picard back to
the moment where he's like right there
in that pool and I'm like oh I wish we
could do that
um so no one is really thinking that
they're going going to say this is how
it happened there are some researchers
who are working on being able to say
this is how it plausibly could have
happened we don't even have the answer
to that then there are researchers who
are working on this is how life in
general arises in general
um trying to abstract from Earth's
chemistry and look at what life
fundamentally is what is the distinction
between
when matter is
ruled by the laws of physics and when
something else kicks in
um one of the big challenges to that is
that we don't have a theoretical
understanding of what life is
um I talk in the book and people often
ask me about like we don't have a
definition for life and it's true we
don't
but that's not because we haven't found
it yet it's because life isn't the sort
of thing for which definitions are
useful and this is drawing on the work
of philosopher of science Carol Cleland
physicist Sarah Walker I don't want to
make it seem like I figured this out
myself
um Sarah's been a guest and Sarah's been
on the show and so is Lee Cronin and
they're both mentioned in that exactly
yeah and so um
Cleland points out that definitions are
useful for understanding what words mean
but they don't tell us fundamentally
what like how the universe works so I
don't need to know what l-i-f-e means
just like saying gravity is the force
that holds me to the Earth doesn't tell
me anything about how the universe works
it doesn't help me understand anything
scientifically and so a definition for
life
isn't going to actually help and that's
why the definition project there's
always something is included that you
like oh my definition accidentally
includes fire or excludes mules because
definitions are not useful here but we
don't have a theory of life and it's
questionable whether we can work towards
one with only one example
um Sarah and Lee are working on
developing a theory of life that
um off the idea that what's fundamental
about life is complexity and the ability
to store information sort of to have a
memory that persists through time but
Cleland says that you just can't do it
from one example you have to get too
abstract you're not actually drawing
from specific evidence and so we have to
go about the search for life
and the study of the origin of life
differently by sort of not trying to be
too constrained by definitions but being
sort of open-minded looking for
anomalies things that are sort of maybe
lifelike and then we dig in deeper there
so it is a tricky field in that we don't
have a clear framework yet and we're
sort of trying to find that framework
and find evidence to build that
framework from and find evidence to
support the framework that we don't
totally have yet so that might be the
sort of murkiness that was it little man
on Twitter was uh was talking about that
we're sort of trying to design the house
and build the house and measure the
house all at the same time
yeah and so the book is reminiscent of
of you know uh other topics that we've
talked about other authors we've had on
recently Carl Zimmer who wrote a book
called life's Edge and I'll ask you a
question that I asked him and uh maybe
made him squirm a little bit but we'll
see if you'll answer it later on uh
you're free not to uh but um but we
talked with our accursion bomb about the
his book The zoologist God to the Galaxy
and there are all sorts of hopes that
there could be other signatures of life
that perhaps are remotely sensible that
we could actually detect from Earth and
I'm going to ask a question this is from
George Anderson over on YouTube this
time and he's asking about uh the fossil
in fossil fuels which which plays a role
in things like Adam
um Frank who passed guest on the show
light of the Stars author uh claims you
know global warming could be perceived
on another planet as evidence of
technological life uh but I'm gonna I'm
gonna gloss over that I usually say you
know to get to have this conversation on
riverside.f FM not sponsored hashtag not
sponsored yet
um that you know we're communicating
over telecommunications you know
Wireless wired you know over trillions
of transistors none of that would be
possible without whale oil you know to
and and uh and the death of many
trillions and trillions of metric tons
of fossil life and so George Anderson's
kind of asking a similar question I mean
how plausible is that to happen on
another planet uh that's one question
but he's asking a different question
he's saying here on Earth when living
things decompose they leave carbon in
layers the carbon has rock layers that
uh that slide on top of each other
during tectonic events which helps
constantly renew our mantle are there
any other traces of life on other
planets that could be used as a
biomarker if not a techno marker but a
biomarker say plate tectonics on another
on an exoplanet is that something we
could hope to sort of divine in our in
our lifetimes
um I don't know if there's hope for
detecting plate tectonics anywhere
outside the solar system
um
there's I mean we're we're beginning to
be able to detect what is in the
atmospheres of exoplanets
um there's work that indicates that we
could
detect the rotation periods and the um
sort of layout of continents just by
being in terms of sort of like light and
dark blotches which is also part of how
you see this the spin because you see
the stuff moving
um but I don't I haven't heard anything
about being able to detect plate
tectonics on another planet that doesn't
mean it doesn't exist that that it's not
an idea but it would
yeah no I was just gonna say can you say
about your feelings on Adam Frank's
Professor Frank's speculation about
global warming tracers
um
I'm not familiar with that I'm familiar
with
sort of conceptually using the idea of
an anthropocene as um
a way to sort of think ourselves through
this moment
you know his his book light of the Stars
I hope that's what it's called
um yeah yeah makes the argument that
like we need to see ourselves within
this Cosmic community of other
civilizations that have hit this
bottleneck this sort of threshold where
our resource use starts making the
planet
harder for us to live in and you know he
models all these different ways that
these hypothetical other civilizations
which he argues like we should not think
of them as hypothetical because he is
not a skeptic pessimist like you
um that not every and then you know when
a when a civilization realizes the error
of their ways and changes their ways
which I wouldn't say we are even at yet
some of them are able to make it through
like that's that's our big big
inspiration but yeah I mean I've also
heard about looking for techno
signatures like an abundance of
Elemental silicon on the surface of a
planet I think that's a Jason Wright
idea that on an Earth-like planet that
would immediately combine with oxygen
and you would get a lot of rocks but if
you have a lot of Elemental silicon
detectable that could be solar panels
that's how you would get that on earth
right so these ideas of looking for
um Elemental abundances or presences
that
on Earth only exist because of
Technology but the problem with all of
these whether it's biosignatures or
techno signatures is they're never going
to to give us a definitive detection
they're always going to be suggestions
or signatures because we don't know that
some exoplanet for whatever reason
doesn't have its own way of keeping a
lot of this surprising element in a
surprising abundance in the atmosphere
on the surface which just goes back to
the problem with the Publix
expectations for what sort of definitive
answers we're going to get
um
it's related to the abiogenesis thing
we're never going to know historically
how it happened on Earth we're going to
know here's how it could have happened
um it's interesting you say that because
Carl Zimmer in his book life's Edge
which we'll get to in just a second just
only tangentially it's about this show
is about your book but you know he
really makes it out that you know we're
it's it's insiping you know we have
we're about to get it
we're about to yeah he's uh your
neighbor over there and yeah he's in New
Haven yeah so uh the nutmeg state
produces a lot of spicy authors right
okay uh anyway the the claim is that you
know he visits all these people he does
experiments on platypi and I don't know
that's the plural or whatever but anyway
he does all these things and experiments
he makes his own DNA from this and that
and he makes okay we're about to
discover it and there are scientists
that are really coming up with uh
definitely but I like that you're that
you're you're not being wishy-washy
you're you're taking a stand that this
is and and I'm not saying you're right
or he's he's right or you're wrong and
he's wrong but that you know there's a
lot of like there are a lot of
wishy-washy well we'll know it when we
see it you know it's like pornography I
suppose uh but you know how how can we
make progress in a field where there is
no definition of what is the thing under
study and he tweeted out the reason I
got him on my podcast because he tweeted
Out imagine if astronomers couldn't
agree what a planet was so that that's
where we're at and I said uh they cannot
I got news for you buddy not only is
Pluto you know kind of still beloved by
many of my colleagues and myself uh but
but there's no one definition anyway
um so I think it's important to take a
stand like you're doing and make make
these claims I think it's it's also
important to do the research and and to
to support you know these kind of
Investigations but as as usual it's the
public is always left in this ambiguous
state of well scientists made life in a
laboratory here in La Jolla and uh at
Craig ventner's laboratory no they
didn't they started with a living cell
and they they extracted some Golgi
bodies and whatever they do over there
uh and they made it into something so uh
or you know that the meteorites that we
talked about or the SEC six other
signatures that you talk about in this
book and so it's a very precarious thing
but I think scientists have to be
careful because if we're not the public
will lose interest to lose support and
will be out of a job so anyway not
expecting you to necessarily reply to
that we have more questions from the
audience unless do you want to follow up
or no I mean I can yeah let's take
another question
okay given that this is from my friend
Bernie Taylor who's a cultural
Anthropologist kind of independent given
that the Drake equation is based on a
statistical analysis of life in our
solar system can the same experience be
numerically simulated or projected into
the cosmos unless there are exactly the
same astronomical conditions
I don't understand the first part of
that because the Dr that saying that
it's based on you know what we know on
Earth
the Drake equation isn't based on that I
would say potential answers to the Drake
equation when people try to fill in
the variables for the Drake equation
they sometimes try to extrapolate from
Earth but
the Drake equation itself I mean it
wasn't even
meant to be solved eventually originally
it was created as an agenda setting
exercise at one of the very first study
meetings I picture Frank Drake like
setting up the chairs in a circle in the
room and he was like oh what should we
talk about today and he wrote I don't
know if the people if you know Carl
Sagan and and whoever else were in their
chairs yet or not but he used it to set
the agenda where if they wanted to work
on
trying to detect signals from other
civilizations they needed a reasonable
assumption they needed to think that it
was reasonable that there might be other
civilizations and so then you say okay
what determines whether there are other
civilizations it's these factors and
then that means those are the factors
that are necessary to investigate in
order to establish the
worthwhileness of seti as a field and so
some of those variables at the time were
known like the approximate rate of star
formation
um some of them were not known at the
time but are better constrained now like
um how many stars have planets how many
planets are Earth-like although you'll
get anything from like two percent to
forty percent for Earth-like depending
on whom you ask and then there's stuff
that we absolutely don't know the answer
and probably never can know the answer
like what fraction of planets that have
life go on to have intelligent life like
you would have to do a survey it was
just not it's not plausible unless we're
talking extremely far future so yeah I
don't think that the Drake equation
rests on
any assumptions other than what Frank
Drake identified as the most important
sort of milestones and there are plenty
of steps between you know
uh life arising and intelligence arising
and different people have made different
arguments about oh this is an important
factor this is a make or break Factor
but I don't I don't think that the uh
Linda Billings calls it the Drake
heuristic which I think is is helpful
because it reminds us that we're not
trying to solve it there isn't one
answer it's a way of framing discussions
that's right yes and just another hat
tip to our brilliant friend Shelley who
won the Drake award the previous the
year prior to Frank Drake's passing last
year
um so I wanted to ask you a
controversial question you're free not
to answer it this is your show but I
asked it in one form or another with
Carl Zimmer too so I figure why not give
it a try so I am Jewish I'm a practicing
Jew and uh in My Religion there is a
clear you know mandate that allows a
woman or you know a person to choose
whether or not to abort a fetus at a
certain age of development it's not
unlimited it's not the entirety of their
of their pregnancy as some laws would
have it
um but I wonder I've often asked this
you know and it's possible to to to do
so and to be stronger about that case in
other words when is it actually killing
or taking the life of another human
being and when does it not count
um forgetting about the actual time
scale that's delineated in the talmud
and how they came to it or whatnot I'm
might surmise that you might be
pro-choice correct me if I'm wrong yeah
so if you're approaches okay fine so
this is what I asked Carl because as
well his book starts off with a quote
from Ben Shapiro is a actually a guest
and friend of the show but he has said
things like life starts at conception
and Carl just radically disagrees with
that but kind of dismisses it because
Ben's just a podcaster in his opinion
anyway
I would like to ask you to do the
following thought experiment we discover
unambiguous evidence that there's a
fetus and it's on 51 Pegasus 51b and
it's just sitting there it's doing its
thing
um with that you know and so it's life
it's not only life it's it's almost like
human life what would that cause you to
revisit your pro-choice you know
position I I know like I've had people
on my show and we talked about veganism
and they actually came to veganism from
studying the problem you know what is
what animals can feel and so forth they
reconsidered their eating meat
um you know I I haven't I only eat meat
but but anyway the point being uh did
does investigating life and it's and
it's improbability does that impact
things on a daily basis in terms of
Choice versus not choice no not at all
because I don't know what that feed us
on another planet is doing but I imagine
it's not inside the body of a pregnant
person who is being potentially forced
to
carry it birth it raise it
um you know my stance on abortion is
more about the pregnant person and about
bodily autonomy and about being able to
choose whether or not you are pregnant
or have a child I've been pregnant I've
had a child I would not wish that on
anyone who does not want to do it
um even for someone who wants to do it
it is
it comes it completely over throws your
life
um and adoption is not an alternative to
pregnancy adoption is an alternative to
Parenting right so still being pregnant
is um
it's a bodily autonomy question and just
like you can't force me to give someone
a kidney in order to keep them alive
that has nothing to do with their status
as a person you can't force someone to
be pregnant
um there it's also not just a biological
question it's incredibly wrapped up with
Social Power structures and who is being
given access to abortion and safe
abortion
um
you know like right that's why I put the
fetus on right right right like when we
talk about well maybe I should rephrase
the quest oh sorry go ahead no no go go
ahead no I was gonna say well maybe I
could rephrase it does that make did
would it make you revisit the question
of what is life or when Life Begins for
example no because
um
like
part of life
because bodies are alive just like my
hand is proof of life but if I cut off
my hand it wouldn't be alive but I don't
want to bring it down to viability
either because I don't think I think
that that's
it's just trying to move the goal posts
and it's still thinking in the
terms of the argument that anti-abortion
and anti-choice people are setting where
they're saying life begins at conception
and pro-choice people say no no it
begins at uh like 28 weeks it begins at
viability it's not about when life
begins because life is a process life is
a system life is a state of being
um this is it's it's not abortion for me
Isn't a question about life it's a
question about bodily autonomy and
power
okay okay good yeah so hopefully we'll
uh look at the constitution of planet
51b and if can I since we'll see what we
can do since we're talking about
abortion can I just mention a book
because you you mentioned so many
brilliant people you've talked to I just
I yeah
I did not expect to talk about abortion
but happened to have it on my day I know
um I do have a large stack of books on
my desk but this book you or someone you
love by Hannah Matthews is um the
subtitle is Reflections from an abortion
Doula it's a beautifully written very
thoughtful book that also is just about
all of the systems of care that are
involved in abortion and giving people
the tools and opportunities to choose
what life they live because I think it's
it's also more it's not just about
choosing whether or not to become a
parent or whether to be pregnant it's
really about the sort of like fulfill
like
self-determination um it's just a really
fantastic book and I as someone who have
always thought of myself as pro-choice
came to understand abortion and its
place in our lives even more deeply from
that so just wanted to mention that
since you brought it up
all right we're gonna wrap up with a
non-controversial question trans rights
um uh now uh gun rights gun rights Jamie
oh not a thing I don't have rights just
just kidding just kidding um so we
always close with a quote from Sir
Arthur C Clarke who's the namesake of
the center that I am associate director
of here at UC San Diego uh called the
RFC Clark Center for human imagination
and that's a quote that is the following
it is the only way of determining the
limits of the possible is to venture
Beyond them into the impossible I like
to use that as a springboard to ask my
beloved guests such as you uh what
advice would you give to yourself as a
20 year old I don't know your age but
maybe you're not 20 anymore but but uh
go back to when you're 20. we have a lot
of young people that listen to this show
uh young men and women give them some
advice to help them have the courage to
do as you have done and go into the
impossible advice to your former self
please
I mean the first thing that comes to
mind you told me what andrean said in
her beautiful partial quote from the
Bible
um
mine is is probably much more specific
to what I needed to hear at age 20.
but I I'm gonna have to just go with my
answer
It Feels So trite but um my answer is
stop dieting
I mean I think that that's very I wish
it's something that I could have come
too much earlier but I also think it
does connect I can connect it to bigger
ideas which is
the ways that we waste time on fighting
ourselves and trying to make ourselves
other than we are rather than
Embrace ourselves and get to know
ourselves and strengthen ourselves and
our relationships to ourselves you know
um you know when you say venturing into
the impossible like you have like I have
I don't know
what exactly
that is but I do know that um
I wish I had wasted less energy and less
time reading nutrition labels who knows
what that might have freed up my
creativity for but I I think it's the
that's the specific version of it for me
but the bigger thing it resonates with
is um
not trying to constrain yourself into a
path or a shape that is not the one that
your
Essence is leading you onto hmm
well Jamie I have good news for you if
you'll subscribe to my newsletter pay my
seminar fee of 99 bucks a week I will
give you the dietary tips that allowed
me to drop five pounds from my chin to
my stomach so Jamie phenomenal author no
I think you've done an incredible job
with this book it's it's really
delightful it's moving especially when
you talk about your son I found that
very moving in your father and and so
forth and and just echoing the meaning
of that you get
from tackling the biggest issues that
human beings uniquely as far as we know
I'll plant a steak you know Adam can say
whatever he wants anyone can say what
Jason Wright there's no evidence for
life anywhere else but right here so
let's take care of it let's imbue each
moment with meaning and this book will
help you do that the possibility of Life
Jamie green a renowned author reviewed
glowingly by past guest a long time ago
annelie newitz in the Washington Post is
one of the top science books of the year
thank you so much for having me